a painstaking and deadly job The soppers
Who clear Minds in Ukraine are nicknamed
hedgehogs by their comrades
sometimes wearing these Canadian
designed spider boots for protection
Ukraine has laid its own minds too but
the majority are Russian
moscow's minds are defending hundreds of
kilometers of Front Line in some places
they are up to 16 kilometers Deep by
some estimates across Ukraine an area
twice the size of the maritimes is now
contaminated by mines even after the
counter-offensive and the war is over it
will likely Take Years or even decades
to clear all the mines or Twisted the
National Assembly President Vladimir
zelenski has appeals to allies for more
expertise and equipment
in the meantime some ukrainians have
taken matters into their own hands like
engineer Vitaly
when these chains rotate they can hit
the ground with a force of one ton
detonating any mine
he has designed a mind flail machine
from a regular excavator and is now
testing it with the Army
we calculated that it destroys 100 of
Mines but if that doesn't prove to be
the case this huge machine can be
controlled remotely to check how its
tracks hold up driving over large mines
machines like this would be sitting
docks on the front line so would only be
used on recaptured land
meaning the work of fearless soppers
will be crucial to any advances Ukraine
makes on the battlefield day after day
inch by inch many of them have died and
will die sacrificing their own future
for that of Ukraine Redmond Shannon
Global News London